hello everybody this is grand master
varakobian and today thursday evening
we're going to do one long class today
we don't have any any big games going on
right now so there's no game of the week
so we decided to do a long class
so this class will be until 8 30 p.m so
about an hour and 15 minutes
we're gonna start off by looking at one
of my games played in a us championship
yeah sorry played in a world team
championship and then we're going to
follow with some exercises on
simplification
and on silent move topics so again after
this game we look at we're going to work
on two topics is a
silent move also known as the quiet move
often
and then we're going to look at the
simplification team okay
all right this game i'm white guys and
i'm playing against run master 2625
ortiz suarez this is played in 2015
at the world team championship in a
match usa
versus cuba okay so knight
f6 i played c4 he played e6
at the moment we don't know yet which
opening my opponent is intending to play
because he can still play in bishop
before
if i play knight city we should be
fourth i'll be nimzo indian defense or
if i play
knight f3 he can play b6 so we don't
know yet
he could have uh he could play any of
these openings he can play d5
queen's game declined and it's not out
of question even the c5 benoni
and guess what after i played knight f3
my opponent responded with
c5 and there we have it guys we have the
benoni defense here okay
so now what to do after c5 the center is
being attacked
and if you want to go for a maximum
advantage you have to try to go for d5
okay
you cannot play some other moves like
you know e3
and expect to have an advantage so i
have to play d5
and you guys should too also if you're
in this position you have to go d5
if you're going for advantage takes
takes
d6
knight c3
g6 now we have been benoni defense and i
like to play this move
bishop to f4 this is what i play often
times okay
against the benoni defense so i play
bishop f4 putting pressure
on d6 now my opponent played
a6 by playing a6 he would like to play
the move b5
and i have to do something about that
after h6
now he wants to play b5 what can you do
here what can i do here to prevent this
i think you guys probably know we have
to play the move
b5 okay the idea is to control
the b5 square
now bishop g7 he plays
bishop g7 now i play the move h3
idea behind this move is i don't want to
be
ever worried about the move knight h5
because 95 i always going to put the
bishop on h2 here
so h3 castles e3
rookie 8
and now i play bishop d3 my idea is just
to castle i would like just to castle to
make sure my king is safe
so after bishop td he plays knight bd7
and it looks like he's just giving me
the pawn but the question is
can i just take on this six would it
would it be a good idea if i take the
pawn
on d6 think about it
would it be a good idea to take on these
six here
all right
it looks like i can just take it but
what is he really trying to do here huh
what is he really trying to do here uh
in this in this opening i'm gonna try to
open the youtube guy so i can see your
i can see your comments okay so
you can type your answers here i can i
can see it
so can i take on these six
okay if i take on d6
now black will play a move queen
to b6 okay putting pressure now
on
d6 and also putting pressure on b2 okay
so if i do that i'm going to be losing
some material now bishop has to go back
for example
and now he takes on b2 okay
and now he takes on b2 okay
yeah and i can see the chat guys so if
you have any questions you can just uh
just type there okay i'll be taking i'll
take a look at it so this is not good
for me guys
because now i have to worry about the
night and the rook is under attack as
well so it's it's not
it's not good uh so that's why i didn't
take it i opted
off to castle but now he plays knight
here guys
knight h5 and he is encouraging me now
to take
okay he's encouraging me to take now
he's encouraging me to take now what
should i do here
should i should i retreat or
maybe i can take in this position maybe
something has been changed
because now my king is at least castled
at least i'm castle so it's not
uh maybe i can do that so let's see here
what should i do here bishop h2 okay you
guys going for the sev siddart
sedan sato yeah satau yes bishop h2
that's the safe option
guys yeah you're playing it safe yeah
bishop goes here
he goes 95 yeah but yeah this is a safer
approach you know
but then he takes takes rook takes
okay this this simplification is going
to help block a little bit okay
they're going to help black a little bit
all right so um what
else what else anybody let's see 92 no
you you can play 92 if you want but
better
better guys all right
uh and then i see a correct answer
suggested by
ar nulfo duenas arnuforduenas
suggests to take on d6 correct
now queen b6 though he
is attacking me now with queen b6 and
the question is now
what am i going to do guys i have this
under attack
and i have this under attack and
suddenly everything is hanging guys
what am i going to do now did i just
blunder
didn't i just blunder this of course not
of course not
we're going to make a positional
sacrifice here no we're not
we are not um blundering here i actually
intended this okay so now he played
queen b6
bishop goes back to h2
retreating the bishop now he goes queen
takes b2
picking up my pawn and now my knight is
under attack but luckily
i have a fantastic square in this
position fantastic square for my knight
here
so here you're gonna see a pure
positional sacrifice okay
pure positional sacrifice by me
to get a pretty dominant position here
94 absolutely gotta centralize the
knight
he takes i take
takes i take
now we arrive to this position here
where we have to think here it's not so
easy so we have to think here what to do
here
in this position
we are a down exchange but we have a
very powerful
bishop on h2 that is just simply a
monster
controlling all these important squares
and now we can try to put this knight
on d6 as well to cement the position of
this knight
there and then follow it up with e4 so
despite
being down exchange i like my position
here quite a lot
looking to put that knight on d6
absolutely and plant it there
planted to this fantastic piece on
d6
now my opponent went knight hf6 i mean
this knight is what is this knight doing
in the corner here
doing nothing so he goes here knight d6
rook e7 e4
now he goes now again again he's got the
material but what to do
he's got the material but nothing is
moving
nothing is moving so he played
knight b6 my opponent
was probably so frustrated that he
couldn't do anything
and decided to sacrifice a piece back to
destroy
my central pawns but i was expecting
that guys
now he goes here now from here man i
want you to take control of the game
and try to find every move that i played
here
what did i play in this position here
let's see i'm going to give you a minute
a minute or two to think what did i play
here from now on you take control of
the game until move 36 when my opponent
simply resigned here
a5 correct attacking the knight
and forcing him now to give up he's not
going back because that's going to be
too much waste of time
so he goes for knight takes d5 as i
explained earlier that's what he wants
to do
i take he takes
now what is my move here now i have
two pieces for a rook but he does have
two puns
but the good thing for me what i have
going is i have my my bishops
and i can try to attack his king i can
try to put pressure here
what should be the next move here for me
guys to keep the pressure going
to have that initiative here you have to
play
actively here yaroslav portis correct
yaroslav bishop c4
very good now putting pressure on the
knight and putting pressure on f7
correct not e4 e4 is okay too guys but
if i go to e4 he just goes here
and then what do i accomplish now i have
to move my bishop okay
so you always want to have purposes in
your moves okay bishop c4 is correct
now he goes knight f6 by the way if he
plays bishop e6
why is this a bad move why is this a bad
move guys if he does this
how can i attack him and put pressure on
he didn't play bishop e6 but why
what move i have here
knight g5 i like that i like that move
absolutely knight g5 putting pressure on
e6
with lots of pressure okay with lots of
lots of pressure okay
so bishop c4 now he played
knight f6 now again you are finding all
the moves now guys you're in command
here
what do we do now how are we going to
put more pressure
how are we going to put pressure on his
position guys ma let's see here
mahmoud kante perfect guys mahmoud kante
both
perfect knight g5 look at this
applying this pressure now on f7 what is
he going to do now to defend against
this f7
weak pawn if he plays bishop e6 i can
even pin him more
i can't even pin him more with this move
okay so that way he cannot do anything
at all
so knight g5
now he played king g7 he abandoned this
pawn
he abandoned f7 okay bishop e6 is not
good chess king rookie one
so many pins so many threats here i mean
just look at this position look at this
tremendous pressure i'm putting on him
pressure
pressure pressure as well here
so much pressure here on black's
position
so he plays kg7 now
now what do you do
okay we take knight gf7 correct
knight g7 and he played bishop d7
9 was bishop d7 now what to do
now what to do
now what can you do here think about it
guys what kind of idea you have
now what do we have here we have to try
to activate
our pieces money i money
i money correct i money bishop e5 of
course
putting pressure putting a lot of
pressure okay
absolutely correct imani now
bishop e5 he goes bishop e6
now what to do here i took now he takes
what are you gonna do now guys this is a
very important moment here
what can you do
now what to do
i want to see the answers here guys
what's the answer here
okay we got some excellent excellent uh
excellent viewership today guys we got
some really strong players in the house
here
and they're finding this grand master
moves no problem
what is the move here guys we want to
play knight g5 we want to bring that
knight back to pressure him
but our bishop is hanging right our
bishop is vulnerable here
what are we going to do here to secure
that bishop right
how do we gonna secure that bishop first
so we have the freedom to move this
knight because
if you move the 90 you're going to lose
this bishop right what you want to do
you want to secure the bishop here
f4 absolutely max schulzberg
yaroslav porsche perfect
claudio absolutely guys excellent work
yes
f4 this is cementing the bishop
and also threatening to play knight g5
okay
now he goes h6
and now you want to put pressure on this
knight how are you going to put pressure
on this knight
we want to try to increase the pressure
so we can try to have
more attacking ideas g4
perfect yes
g4 perfect now he plays g5
now he is trying to stop me from playing
g5
what should i do now
i would like to press him and gain as
much space as possible
h4 h4 uh
something about h4 i wasn't completely
sure h4
i of course i calculated h4
h4 what else f5 correct
f5 correct matthew first matthew was
first f5
absolutely now attacking the rook
attacking that rook now he has to go
back here on e7 look at this
now he's completely squeezed he cannot
go anywhere
now what are we gonna do here we need to
put pressure i need you to put more
pressure now
on the pawn now
how can we do that how we can put more
pressure
rook b1 yes because we are anticipating
we are anticipating
him to take this i take he takes i go
here
go see right take
winning a piece okay
so that's why he didn't take right away
so he played here
now look f8
now we need to figure out what to do
here this this
this is the key moment here guys he's
threatening now to take on uh
f7 you know he wants to
let's say if you don't pay attention you
go here
takes takes and king takes and now your
knight
the bishop is under attack so black is
untangling here
so what can you do in this position to
keep that pressure on
you want to put the grip on the position
here guys
absolutely rook b6 gabrielle silva first
chess king right after him fantastic
rook b6 guys
fantastic now putting pressure okay
rook b6
now he played
rook ff7
takes rook f7 now i'm down upon here
but one very important thing guys i have
a question how
is he ever gonna get out of this pin
here
how is he ever gonna get out of this
absolutely
uh no sivasha absolutely zuksavank okay
pretty much a zuksavan for him he cannot
do anything here even though he's
up a pawn he cannot do anything this is
just fine
very nice and a very important squeeze
right now going on on
on f6 okay so now rook f7
what do we do now guys what do we do
king f2 of course green
bring the king in the game rook f8 now
guys don't rush
he's trying to set up something okay
he's trying to set
up something what can you do
if you go here guys the whole point of
this move if you go here he's gonna pin
you
and then now if i take rook f6 he's
gonna take check
and he's gonna pick this rook up okay
so if you go to key six
takes takes
and he goes here and he's it's gonna get
out of this this
and this
so what can we do here of course we're
not falling for his trick here guys
one more move to cement your advantage
here
what is that move that you're gonna play
now to cement your advantage guys
rugby seven is good don't get me wrong
it's winning
but it's not the best okay it's good
but not the best but i want you to find
the best here
i want you to win this game without
giving opponent any contra player here
you have him in this huge pin here you
don't want the pin to go away
you want to keep that huge pin rook e6
first
gabrielle silva correct gabriel
rook e6 taking away any
of his counter play ideas with rookie
seven so he can no longer do any of that
okay
so now he has nothing else to do but to
sit
okay and now he sits and now
we can improve our king the journey
continues
the journey continues all the way to
c5 right k3
okay perfect ke3 now
rook f8
yeah gabriel silva is on fire today guys
yes
all right but anyway you know i'm i
maybe some of you mentioned it earlier
as well you know
that's fine great job great job
everybody now what are we going to do
now king d3 mahmoud of course
now we're going to go king c4 to get the
pawn on c5
what is he going to do guys
now you're gonna go king c4 and picking
up the material and guess what
he played rook f7 and resigned without
even awaiting my move because it's
pretty clear
i'm gonna go here and i have no
intentions to take on b6
no intentions until the time is right
you know
until the time is right because i have
him in such a nice pin here i would like
a stick now and again here i have
such a strong pin here i'm gonna just
improve my king
i will only take here now
when you know he can take take
a6 and quinn so one of my favorite games
guys and this guy i defeated was 26
25 feeder rated grand master
kuba's number three suarez ortiz
okay so
uh that's a good question uh atul
uh sharma why i don't show last games i
think i did actually
i've showed last games you haven't
watched it we had
a class my greatest losses
my grace is losses atul atul sharma
watch that one i show my loss against
ikaru nakamura
which cost me the u.s championship in
2017.
check out that class my greatest losses
that was a big one
you know big one i was going to be a u.s
champion head i won that game okay
all right well anyway guys
i hope you enjoyed this game
yeah i've also hit show you the game
against hikaru as well sure the win as
well okay
no this is not my last lesson no i'm i'm
also doing lessons on sunday guys
but also yeah i'm gonna do i'm working
for the chess club this week
so sunday will be my last day but then
after that you can see me on my youtube
channel at varacobian
okay and also on twitch gm
varacobin okay after this week i'll be
starting my
you know more streaming and more things
like that so you can see me online guys
so anyway i hope you enjoyed this game
but we're going to continue now because
as i mentioned
i prepared two other different topics
for you okay
two other topics and right now we're
gonna talk about something very
important guys
it's called the silent move okay
uh h4 oh question why did i play h4
instead of f5
uh
yeah i would like to answer the question
so
h4 here
i probably could i probably could have
done that
um
and i'm trying to remember i'm really
trying to think hard to remember
there was something like this i guess
you can do
yeah sunday classes on twitch guys i got
three classes okay
ah this i have this yeah so yeah why i
didn't play h4 i i don't i don't
remember
you know but
it's h4 yeah h1 looks very good too okay
it's probably winning two guys
some perk defense arnold for a perk
defense
uh that's a little bit different topic
by itself
i'll cover how about this i'll cover i
do like a perk tutorial on my youtube
channel okay and you can watch that okay
because that's going to be something
more specific for the specific audience
you know so i don't know if
we have 107 people watching us i don't
know if they all want to see the perk
defense you know
but anyway but i think most of you
almost all of you will benefit from
learning what is silent move
so let's begin
our first position so let me pull up my
silent move positions
okay guys this positions are designed
for uh higher
pretty high ranked students okay and
high ranked chess players so
i think but i think you can totally
handle this guys
we have some really strong players today
watching us
and being very active participating so
you found some really strong grand
master moves today so
i think you can definitely handle this
position okay
by the way these are all played by
grandmasters these examples
i don't have their old names saved up
but they're all pretty much played by
grandmasters okay so
if you find a solution that means you're
playing like a grandmaster
okay so you should be very proud of
yourself
for finding the solution here all right
position number one silent move where is
your youtube channel my youtube channel
is varacobian
uh right now i have couple of uh videos
there from my
twitch channel that i did okay but uh
just just look up
varacobian gm varacobian on youtube and
you'll find it okay
or if you look at my uh go to my twitch
there is a link there as well okay
my twitch is gm varacobian guys so you
can you can follow me there
and uh so you can see my streams okay
so white to play and win guys
why to play
okay chess king i think you've seen most
of my stuff so don't
if you know the position chess king i
chess king is this
my student young adi adi panda so he
he basically knows a lot of my materials
okay
so that chess king guy is very good
adi if you know it you don't need to you
know because
you know for adi i have to create
material every day new stuff you know
because he's like
he knows my studies he knows my games he
knows
you know so the guy the guy does like a
lot of chess every day you know that's
chess king
the guy in the chat you know all right
what's the move here guys it's a silent
move guys
silent move so queen h7 wouldn't be uh
explained as a silent move because he'll
just go king f8
so what would be a silent move idea
do
all right so what's the move here rook
h3 preparing rook h1 okay
rook h3 now
that's correct so if he takes check
what kind of what move we have here guys
uh it's not a checkmate there uh sean
simon
it's not a checkmate he goes k7 there
rook g3
savisha perfect and now we're just
basically going to take on g7 and win
the game after this okay
so he's in big trouble so let's look at
some of the critical lines here that
could happen here okay
so let's say he plays
queen g6 this is the best defense
and now you have to play a very
important move here
don't rush guys there might be some
tempting options but again
i i want you not to rush many many don't
rush okay
it's not always about the most natural
move
mahmud don't rush
yeah see you guys saying this move but
i think you might have missed this check
you might have missed this check guys
because now when you take i take back
with this and now i have an
escape square to go to on f7 okay
now king goes to f7 and just escaping
okay
all right
so
yeah that that's okay probably still
white has some pressure here but again
we
we we're missing the win here so correct
move here
is f5 f5 again by chess king
now he goes here
now what do we do guys
we can't take on g3 red see dart
siddhant bishop will take you sit down
you can't take it
f4 michael
michael carlos yes attacking that queen
attacking that queen and the queen
cannot do much so if he goes here now
look at this thank you very much
attacking the queen
he goes here and now how are we going to
chop this queen here
how
absolutely guys absolutely rook h1 and
now he cannot do anything
and the queen is dropped
perfect i think we cover all the
violations guys
i think we cover all the violations here
but the question i have to you we have
about 100 people watching us
how many of you would have think about
the move rook h3
if you hadn't done exercises like this
how many of you
would think about the move like rook h3
in a real game again when nobody is
telling you there is a silent move or
anything
what is the idea
anybody yeah i don't know i don't know
if i would have seen it guys i mean i
might
because i've done a lot of exercises
like this but again it's not easy
okay yeah i agree i agree
yeah f3 is more natural
why not f3 from the beginning you could
mahmud you could mahmud but
queen g6 i don't know i mean
we're probably still better here mahmoud
but
i don't know i mean this here goes this
this it goes this
yeah but queen h7 i understand you would
have played queen h7 but if there is no
good follow-up what is queen h7 gonna do
to us you know
what's our follow-up though
you know i mean check
check
take take
okay all right guys we're gonna look at
the next position ready
okay a chess king you might know this
position don't put
any answers on the chat okay if you know
this position
because chess king is actually uh taking
a chess camp here guys
every day in the mornings and
and you know he he has seen some of this
stuff
you know some of this stuff i'm not
saying every stuff but so chess king
gets his afternoon training also
that that that camp is for young
students okay
who live in uh you know it's for young
well i guess it's not for
there are some adults there as well so i
don't know uh
but yeah let's see this one now
all right block to play and win
block to play and win guys what are you
going to do here
uh in that line he goes rational
function test
he plays king f8 at the end of that line
king of faking is seven and
i don't know if we have a win there
we might have some win but it's okay
don't don't need to sit no need to say
it chess king yeah i know
you you know see my job should be
finding new materials for chess king you
know
find new stuff for chess king i'm going
to give you some book recommendation
chess king you should do some book
recommendations okay
you know you should do like chess cafe
puzzle books or something you know
there are four of them chess cafe puzzle
books guys
all right what are we doing here guys i
want you to think i want you to sink in
into the position okay
i don't want you to just uh i want you
to sink in into position to find the
best moves okay
not any move but the best moves
all right let's see if we can figure
this one out
why to play block to play and win guys
block to play how how we gonna find the
winning continuation it's amazing
amazing move here
we are going to see here
and i see i see a lot of moves flying
out there
but i don't see any variations guys
you're just giving me moves
you're just giving me moves guys i want
variations okay
uh somebody said queen f3
takes here we can he go here
i mean is this so clear
i don't know this
might not be very clear you know
something in this because d5 is hanging
too
all right so i think we got the first
move here many of you said king f7
okay but i i need the whole
whole concept here okay so first of all
if he takes with the
queen here what do you do
adi panda yeah the young one he's
playing his skills
strong one actually yeah
uh what's the move here
guys try to give me the variation not
just the move the whole variation
whole variation here i want to see
okay chad correct it takes continue
check
check
animate perfect
perfect
so that doesn't work
the other option is
if he goes knight c5
attacking your queen what are you gonna
do
yep correct it takes continue
perfect
all right now king f7 now we're going to
go for
another variation that is very important
okay
rook de-3 now what do you do now this
gets a little complicated this gets a
little messy here guys
so what is the idea now
well rook h1 he'll take your queen
no but he goes king f2 yaroslav yaroslav
he'll go
look uh he'll go king f2 in that line
not g2
f2 e3
queen b1 check correct okay so he cannot
go here because of this check
we just established that
so
if he goes here
why is this move losing guys
now we're gonna what are we gonna do now
okay
and made perfect
uh
yeah so that's the problem with that
because we have rook h1 and mate and now
the last one
guys if he plays rook f1 why is rook f1
losing here
why is rook f1 losing
no problem ziyad khalifa zehad khalifa
no problem we're glad you're with us
okay make sure
when the video is uploaded you can see
the first half because
we had a very very nice game that i
showed against grandmaster ortiz
so make sure you watch the first half
okay
so silent move here silent move guys
it's black to play and win block to play
and win
queen takes b3 by teal ingeman
till ingeman finds it takes
rook takes and bishop d4 with
devastating
consequences and if he takes now only 8
what are we gonna do
queen takes what are we going to do guys
come on
yep check and now the killer the killer
blow here is
bishop takes d4 correct check
and basically it goes here check
check on take
all right very good guys that's the
solution for this one
again same question goes to you how many
of you would find the move
king f7 in a real game i think this one
is maybe a little bit easier guys to
find
i think this one is a little bit easier
how many of you would come up with this
idea
i think there might be a slight
difference but i think king g7 is also
winning max
schlossberg
i like f7 better because it covers the
e7 e7 square a little bit better
it covers that e7 square a little bit
better i think that's why
but there might be a difference too okay
so that's fine you don't want that
uh this one maybe the last one no
all right very good guys we're gonna
continue now
one more silent move okay
one more silent move i want to share
with you today
all right this one is really nice
all right white to play and win
this is a game i believe eliano pavel
elianov against
sergey karjakin okay and again
silent move
this will be your probably last silent
move position guys
because i want to do a couple of more
simplifications for you okay
so probably the last silent move for
today
please calculate a little bit guys
minute or two calculate please
okay i see some solutions here knight g5
but you have to calculate after knight
g5
what's gonna happen if opponent gonna
take on g2 what is your
follow-up guys yeah this is the game
eliano
versus sergey karjakin nice work by ben
simon
quickly finding the exact uh the game
and the year as well yeah
okay um
yeah well if you go knight f4
unfortunately
they're giving me a little break and
he'll take your night
and take you might still be a little bit
better but you're not winning here
you're nowhere
nowhere near winning okay
you're nowhere near winning here guys
so what is the move here knight g5
that's correct
now now there are two options here one
is bishop takes g2 which is the most
obvious one and now how do we follow it
up from
well 96 is nice but what if i take
now check i go here
yeah check you might even block it with
this okay
now you have to figure out one thing the
knight on f6
is the obstacle okay and you have to
figure out a way to eliminate the
obstacle okay
and that is rook f4 with idea
take on f6 okay
now whatever he does next move you're
gonna sacrifice
on f 6
takes and mate sacrifice and mate
all right so knight g5
what if he plays the move e5
now what if he plays e5 because now he
wants to cover the
f4 square and also at the same time he's
hitting the rock
he's also hitting the rook at the same
time now what are we going to do now
to deal with this idea
rook t5 i don't know about rook d5 guys
i'm not sure
bishop b7 by david 2089 by david
2089 bravo david
taking it takes back returning with
bishop d5
and now if he takes your bishop you have
a checkmate
on h7 and now he cannot stop the
powerful queen g6 threat
this move cannot be stopped guys there
is no way to stop this
queen g6 threat either he gets mated or
he's gonna have to allow
the move queen to g6
everybody understand this position
yeah bishop b7 and bishop d5 this is
fantastic
bishop d5 that is a silent move guys
that is a silent move that finishes the
game
very very powerful move to play okay
very nice i agree alex
yeah these are actual games guys these
are actual games you can see the name
you can take a picture of this and look
up the whole game guys
take a picture or write down the names
of the players okay
all right very good moving forward now
as i promised we're going to change this
topic a little bit now
and we're going to do a couple of
positions with the team called
simplification
okay
all right white to play and win
and this is a game over ukrainian grand
masters kofschan i believe
koftchan alexander koftson is white
why to play what to do thanks for
yeah absolutely guys moving forward to
the next topic
which is called simplification okay
simplification
calculate a little bit so you can find
the idea here white
to play white to play and win
white to play and win you have to
calculate really deeply because
you're simplifying but you have to make
sure you simplify into the winning
endgame not to simplify and to draw an
end game
gm silent movies like a swish and zook
um yeah sometimes it's a swish and silk
yeah
it's all depending on the position
arnulfo
arnolfo it depends on the position
bishop b6 and promoting mark marco di
cesar but what if he takes back with the
bishop marco
yeah i want calculation guys i want
somebody who can calculate
five six moves here and put that in the
chart not like one moves
one move is not going to do it guys i
want somebody who can deeply calculate
this
you're welcome slavash sivash
sivash you're welcome i enjoy working
with you guys and
they have a very good group today you
guys doing an amazing job okay today
these are not easy positions okay these
are not easy positions at all
bishop b6 bishop b6 a b c5 and the king
enters easily without calculation zayat
khalifa
and there was still calculation there
because
it's move by move zayd it's very mobile
move at the end okay
but okay we are on the right track here
so bishop b6 correcto now if he takes
back
why is this losing guys very quickly why
is this losing
why is pawn takes losing guys
a6 correct max and now you're promoting
this okay so he has to take back with
the bishop
all right you take right and now here
what is the key move without this move
you can forget about winning this
position guys
simply forget about it what's the
winning move
c5 bravo now
you have to calculate this you have to
calculate this
if it takes you're winning by a tempe
you play king c4 king d5 you take
and now which move you're going to play
to put him in
such a wanker
perfect
if he goes here you shoulder him away
you use the shouldering method okay
shouldering method guys
to push him away from his pawn and win
the game
if he goes back king b7 now you're
entering this way guys
boom boom and boom
boom boom and win the game got it
perfect so
now we're down to the last attempt b5
now how are we gonna win in this case
guys
how are we going to win in this scenario
this is very straightforward
before what what mean before guys
you're not saying pawn before are you
oh you're not saying pawn before do you
guys
king before of course this is your route
guys
this is your route and you're gonna get
in here here okay
now if he goes here again you go here if
he goes here you can just go here and
use the shouldering method
to push him away and win his pawn
okay but now he goes here
he is suddenly trying to make an attempt
with this
king b6 king d5 and now again
you have a move that puts him into that
success
what is the move that puts him in a
suksawan guys
yep now you play before correct
now he goes here takes takes
here and push
and we win okay all right
that was very good guys once again
so many details so many details but what
is bishop b6
ultimately ultimately what is bishop b6
accomplishing that is very important
guys
what is bishop b6 accomplishing it
ultimately guys
it's accomplishing d simplifying
correct max correct game master sim
plification
simplifying the position okay
simplifying to the winning this is
important when you can understand when
you get strong enough you understand
when you simplify to a winning endgame
that's going to bring you a lot of
points okay
simplification remember simplification
and the last position for today guys i
really enjoyed uh
the to work with you today today was i
think a very
a lot of fun okay so and
now this position here
and this is a i would i would i would
make this a simplification and
unexpected bit of surprise bit of
unexpected
situation here okay
a bit of unexpected way of winning the
game
but it's just again calculation
calculation and calculation
all right guys the last position for
today
white to play and win okay
why to play and win guys
how you can do this okay i believe this
is a game of a famous grand master from
poland
radoslav waitashik okay
i'm sure ben ben simon will find this
game
momentarily this is a game of polish
number two or number one
it depends when you look at it there is
also grandmaster duda from poland
but why to play and win
you're welcome las aventuras you're
welcome you're very welcome i'm glad
you're enjoying the
names of indian defense one of my
favorite openings against d4
i need you guys to calculate siddharth
she don't calculate
not just one move guys i want
calculation please
i want complete calculation okay
one two three
one two three four
five moves five moves guys five moves
okay
i need somebody who can calculate five
moves and bring the victory all the way
guys
all the way you have a very unexpected
but very forced win here
which will take you five moves to do it
okay unexpected
but forced way to win this
f4 guys f4
i tank did you miss this
did you miss my capture
how is the queen trapped guys
i don't know guys i think you just
missed this take
all right
well well that's what you gotta find
manny that's what you gotta find
g5 i'm not going to set up a position
for you if you're going to be able to
win the game with one move
you know you guys way stronger than that
so for me to set up mate
you know one more win for you you guys
wasteful there you go
zayat zayat khalifa is finding the
solution
continue now guys yeah it's not this is
not just winning the game guys you still
have to calculate the block has a
resource okay
and i need you to calculate those
resources okay
those resources
i need somebody who can give the whole
thing guys the whole thing i want
ok marco d correct but it's not trapped
yet
bishop f3 keep going black hasn't moved
there marco
oh that that line doesn't work kk91 that
that line is not that good
i mean i can just take back only six kk
kk91
queen h6 which position queen h6 uh
z zayat queen h6 win
all right continue continue i see an
answer
almost complete answer i see an answer
right there
i'm not gonna say your name yet but
you're close
i see an answer you're very close one
move away
to have a complete solution here
one guy one student one participant has
it
and that is correct yaroslav
porsche yaroslav porsche gets this one
guys
rook g5 attacking the queen now where is
the queen gonna go guys
has to take we take
he takes now we need to attack this
queen okay
boom every square you see here is taken
by your pieces
he has to go here and now we continue
with
which move yaroslav
g3 yes attacking it also this was
suggested by go brazil
go brazil yes now queen is trapped he
has to take it
and now simply quiet move
this is also silent move guys
simplification
followed by a silent move you know
bishop g2 and guess what
the queen is trapped guys and that is
game over right there okay this is a
game rados live boy tashek versus d
janaska played in poland
so make sure you look at the whole game
but i can tell you this
block missed this he didn't think his
queen is getting trapped here okay
he did not think of that so and but this
is again
ability to calculate deeper and believe
in a potential of your position okay
believing in the potential of your
position okay
so remember that guys rook g5
takes take bishop f3
queen h4 g3 takes bishop g2
excellent job guys i'm really really
glad we had a great turnout today
and make sure you catch me this week my
last day will be sunday
i have lectures like this and then after
that you can tune in to my
youtube channel varacobian and the
twitch gm varacobian
where i will have similar content for
you on a regular basis
talking about these different aspects of
the game simplification
silent move and many many others okay
this was just a small portion of it okay
small portion of it there are a lot more
exercises we have okay
and of course thanks to ben simon for
his excellent work obviously guys
this is in a studio we did this today in
a professional san luis chess club
studio with the best equipment
so i think you could hear me and see me
well so
we had a good good setup today thank you
everybody thank you
chess king siddhant gabrielle silva
everybody
thank you thank you appreciate the
compliment gabrielle
and i will see you guys on saturday
hopefully and there will be a tournament
french defense tournament on saturday
and then sunday will be
lectures day okay thank you yaroslav you
did an amazing job today yaroslav that
was excellent okay
some good calculations and uh
i will see you guys very soon okay and
thanks again for everybody joining us we
had a great turnout today okay
see you soon bye-bye
you